ukraine's military chief doesn't look or  sound panicked about the threat of any  new russian invasion  just back from a daily briefing with the  president he signaled his troops are  ready for anything  if there were to be a large-scale  invasion of ukraine are you confident  that your forces would be able to resist  and push them back  ukraine isn't a member of the nato  alliance but dozens of british troops  have been on a training mission here  since  and are you 2015  that nato has said that they would not  actually send troops to fight alongside  the ukrainian forces should there be a  further invasion  tough talk from a veteran who once  commanded troops in the east fighting  russia-backed insurgents  it's a front line that's still active  but relatively calm for now  debra haynes sky news kiev